yo creo que de hecho una de las grandes
lecciones que aprendió el presidente yo
baiden habiendo sido el vicepresidente
de barack obama es que no se tomaron los
pasos contundentes en ese momento para
detener esa invasión lo que estamos
viendo en este momento es uno de los
temas seguramente que tendrá que
discutir y presentar ante el pueblo
estadounidense el presidente yo baiden
es la necesidad no solamente de crear
este consenso internacional con países
de la otan con países de países
latinoamericanos o los países de la
unión europea de crear un frente común
ante esta ante la agresión rusa pero en
ese mismo discurso también tiene que
justificar el dolor y pues los costos
que podría haber para la economía
estadounidense de estas decisiones que
se están haciendo particularmente como
lo menciona estoy muy bien en un momento
en donde la inflación está en un alto
histórico y en donde no se ve que se
pueda resolver este problema de
inflación particularmente en este
momento antes canciones que se están
llevando a cabo desde su perspectiva
eeuu está haciendo suficiente en medio
de esta crisis o debería jugar un papel
diferente
interesante tu pregunta porque lo que
seguiría probablemente y lo que algunos
críticos podrían estar pidiendo es que
tuviera una presencia militar eeuu en
este conflicto y yo creo que el el eso
está
muy lejos de ser una de las
consideraciones pero lo que sí está
sucediendo es que se está proporcionando
armas probablemente se está
proporcionando inteligencia
probablemente se está proporcionando
ciertas capacidades que tiene eeuu la
otan y países europeos para asegurar la
protección de civiles entonces en cierta
forma lo que lo que son las sanciones
económicas probablemente va a ser el
factor que podría ayudar a detener la
agresión
eventualmente o encontrar una una
solución el problema de sanciones
económicas como lo sabes tú con tu
auditorio es que no son no son
inmediatas el impacto y entonces habría
que ver en qué momento
vladimir putin va a buscar una salida al
conflicto pero creo que todavía falta
falta días y posiblemente semanas a eso
bueno vemos esta atención internacional
y también hay tensión dentro del país ya
usted lo mencionaba debido a los efectos
económicos de la pandemia que podemos
esperar del pronunciamiento de byd en
esta noche
y yo creo que entre otras es buscarle el
apoyo del pueblo estadounidense
justificación de este de este apoyo y la
necesidad de crear un consenso
internacional
y sobre todo entender por qué va a haber
este un impacto económico en los
bolsillos de los estadounidenses y por
otra parte yo creo que va a tratar de
crear consenso alrededor de los grandes
temas que ha puesto sobre la mesa una
reforma una reforma electoral y
conseguir apoyos y más más apoyo a la
población más necesitada
eeuu y no me sorprendería que va a
tratar de usar este discurso para tratar
de crear una más unidad dentro del
partido demócrata en un momento en donde
se ha visto o se ha percibido divisiones
importantes señora salazar a usted
muchas gracias por su análisis y por
compartirlo con nosotros en france24
estamos pendientes de lo que ocurra esta
noche con el discurso del estado de la
unión del presidente joe biden